foreign
omics is a theory a physical Theory it's
ethereum physics and it's a very unusual
theory in a certain way it's so unusual
that it's been recently called The
Village witch so in this review article
liddara and colleagues say that a
physical theories were people
thermodynamics would be the village
witch the other theories find her
somewhat odd somehow different to Nature
than the rest yet everybody comes to her
for advice and nobody dares contradict
her
So today we're going to look a little
bit about a couple of demons that have
kind of haunted the history of
thermodynamics before I get on to the
demons I'm first going to tell you a bit
about what thermodynamics is so
thermodynamics arguably applies to lots
of different types of systems some
people think it even applies to black
holes brains but the kind of origin of
the theory uh comes from the Industrial
Revolution so it's a theory from quite a
while ago
um and the kind of typical system that
thermodynamics applies to that you can
kind of keep in mind for this talk
um is a gas so the kind of classical
picture of a gas you can think of as
being a kind of set of billiables all
bouncing into each other right molecules
whizzing around at incredibly High
velocities very very tiny and a very
large number of them so in a kind of uh
a small a small water bottle full of gas
that would have you know 10 to the 23
it's a very very large number uh of uh
molecules in that gas so you can think
of them as whizzing around okay and
there's kind of two different properties
that you can assign to each of those
molecules
um first you can think of the position
of each molecule where it is and you can
think of how fast that molecule is
moving so these are kind of the two
properties for each molecule you can
think well this one's moving at five
kilometers an hour this one's moving at
however fast you know but they're the
different uh velocities that each
molecule could be moving at and if you
specify the position and velocity of
each molecule you've specified the
microstate of the system so you've kind
of said what's going on uh with the gas
and there's lots of different ways the
gas could be right imagine uh
switching this molecule here with the
position of that molecule there right
you've now got a different micro state
of the gas the kind of list of
properties that you assign the position
and velocity for each molecule you've
now got a different list
for the gas so you've got a kind of a
range of different possible microstates
that you could assign to the gas and you
can think of these as kind of being
encoded in what physicists sometimes
called the state space it's kind of
telling you the possibilities
that apply to the gas
um and obviously this state changes over
time
um because the gas molecules are
whizzing around they're changing their
position they're changing their location
right
um and so you can think of that as uh
kind of the state of the system changing
over time moving through the space of
possibilities okay so that's the kind of
uh classical picture of aghast kind of
hold in mind so now what is
thermodynamics okay
so thermodynamics
um that you might have thought was kind
of dealing with micro variables like the
very small we're getting assigning
properties to each uh each molecule in
the gas we're now going to move kind of
upper level to the kind of macro level
so we've got instead of talking about
micro variables like position and
velocity or momentum
um we're going to talk about macro
variables like pressure volume and
temperature
and what's really crucial to
thermodynamics is that these macro
variables are not changing right they're
not changing in time you can imagine uh
you know the glass of water uh its
temperature is constant and so you can
think of it as being in an equilibrium
state if the volume the pressure and the
temperature temperature of the glass of
water aren't changing
um then it's in an equilibrium state so
this is the kind of the crucial thing
for thermodynamics instead of talking
about the state space where we assign
the microstates with all the positioning
velocities now we've got uh these macro
variables which aren't changing in time
so one thing you'll notice about that is
that if the system's in an equilibrium
state
then by definition nothing happens we
said that the the macro variables are
not changing in time
so this means that unlike other physical
theories
um there are no spontaneous Dynamics
um so in the case of the gas whizzing
around you know you have a state of the
system and it was changing over time now
we're talking about macro variables
which aren't changing so there's no
spontaneous Dynamics over time
and this um is unusual for a physical
Theory and it's something that's puzzled
people as a kind of recent controversy
about how to understand processes in
thermodynamics and it goes back to the
work of
um this is the picture here is Tatiana
Aaron Fest Assam who's kind of been
slightly lost from the history um of
physics you wrote a book with her then
husband uh Paul erinfest it's well known
as one of the founders of quantum
mechanics and she wrote about how uh
the processes in thermodynamics are a
little unusual and not like what we're
used to in physics there's no
spontaneous Dynamics in this way so you
might think thermodynamics is a slightly
badly named theory if there aren't
Dynamics in the usual sense why is it
called thermodynamics well
um the etymology of the name comes
actually from not the kind of usual way
we think about Dynamics so normally in
physics we have hydrodynamics
electrodynamics classical Dynamics you
know kind of a series of X Dynamics uh
theories in thermodynamics uh actually
the name has a slightly different
meaning which is uh Thermo means heat
and work is referred to by the Dynamics
work or power so heat and work are very
Central uh to thermodynamics
so what are heat and work so this
equation says that the change in energy
so the D is like the differential so the
change in energy of the system is the
change in energy due to heat plus the
change in energy due to work and you
might think well
that's a little unsurprising the idea
that energy is conserved is kind of like
a Cornerstone of modern physics so
essential violations of that seem kind
of unimaginable and to us uh the kind of
D the e in this equation is kind of the
most well understood quantity uh in that
equation but that historically that
wasn't so
um so historically you can work uh were
better understood uh than energy
but that was at a time when the
metaphysical picture that what the
nature of um heat was was vastly
different from what we think today
so
previously heat was thought to be an
invisible fluid known as caloric
and caloric has some kind of explanatory
successes
for instance the idea that the kind of
particles in the invisible fluid would
repel each other could explain why heat
flows from cold to hot if the you know
the invisible particles of caloric
repelled each other then that would
explain it go from the kind of high
density to the lower density right this
was a theory of Lavoisier and so whilst
it was successful in in some ways
clearly we no longer believe in caloric
but also it was kind of shown to not
quite fit the bill
um in the following way so uh another
character in the kind of history of
thermodynamics
um is somebody called William Thompson
who is later known as count Rumford
um and he was overseeing uh
artillery uh kind of production in
Munich he kind of uh
fled from America and in fact actually
the English Gardens in Munich were his
design
um but he he was overseeing this uh
artillery and he saw that when they were
kind of boring holes in cannons there
was kind of No Limit to the amount of
heat that was generated which didn't
seem to really fit with
um how people thought about caloric
because the idea was that eventually
you'd run out of heat you'd run out of
the kind of invisible fluid right and he
also kind of compared kind of shards of
metal that came out of kind of boring
cannons
um with ones which had had not been kind
of undergone this kind of process and
they didn't seem very different whereas
really the caloric Theory would say they
should be quite different because one
had contained caloric and the other
didn't
so he came to the conclusion
that the kind of source of the heat was
generated by friction and it didn't seem
to run out which if you thought it was a
fluid you'd think eventually you'd run
out of uh run out of the fluid so he
concluded that heats cannot possibly be
a material substance and instead
concluded that it must be motion so that
was the kind of uh end of the caloric
Theory
um and there's a kind of gossipy twist
so lavace was famously beheaded in the
in um in the French Revolution and Not
only was his theory show not to be
correct to add insult to injury uh run
for them married his widow
so we no longer think of heat and work
in the uh in those terms how do we think
of them now today
so we think of heat and work as being
two different types of energy transfer
so heat you can think of as being the
kind of random motion of the molecule so
if you have a box of gas or I don't know
think of a balloon uh you put it next to
a radiator
energy as heat gets transferred to uh
the balloon the molecules start moving
faster
that's a different type of energy
transfer then imagine having a box of
gas and then you push in a piston
compressing the gas
or the gas can do work on the piston and
expand uh expand uh the the volume of
the box so that they're kind of two
different ways of thinking about it so
so Maxwell one of the another kind of
key figure in the history of
thermodynamics referred to this as
ordered versus disordered motion so why
do we care about this distinction
between two different uh types of energy
transfer well now people in philosophy
care about if they want to understand uh
kind of what physical theories are
telling us but at the time there was
kind of a much more prosaic uh
consideration which was they wanted to
be able to build steam engines
so the idea here is so you know instead
of a candle as is in the picture you can
imagine you know a Coal Fire kind of
underneath the uh box of gas in the
steam engine right so what happens is
energy is transferred to the gas as heat
so you kind of uh the energy associated
to the gas increases because you've
heated it up using uh well a candle or a
Coal Fire
the gas then does work on the system so
it uh pushes the Piston so what we've
done is we've transferred energy uh as
heat into work and work is useful right
work is what allows if we have this
piston that gets pushed up you can
imagine that being attached to some kind
of crank but then turns the wheels of
the seam engine so that's the kind of
thing that we want to be able to get out
of the system
useful work but they're kind of limits
to this so we can trans transform heat
into work
but no we can't transfer all the energy
as heat into work and this is one way of
saying what the second law of
Thermodynamics is about
there are limitations on how much energy
can be transferred as heat and then can
be converted into work so uh one
statement of the second law is this it's
impossible to perform a cyclic process
with no other result then that heat is
absorbed from a reservoir and that work
is done but the more familiar version
you might have in mind of the second law
is this idea that entropy can't decrease
so this quantity here this DS s is
normally used to represent entropy
there's this quantity and it can't
decrease in these thermodynamic cases so
when when we transfer energy uh to the
gas by the coal fire we that causes the
Piston to move
uh and then
uh that will then run the steam engine
but we can't use all of the energy and
in particular we can't do it in such a
way that entropy would decrease so what
is entropy now there's lots of different
uh definitions and types of entropy
when one of the founders of quantum
mechanics came up with a new quantity he
said to another person come with another
yes another definition of entropy you
know
you've got this quantity it looks a bit
like entropy call it entropy because
nobody really knows what entropy is and
so you'll always have the upper hand in
an argument
um so if you just want a kind of
heuristic way to think about entropy for
the purposes of this talk you can think
of it as being a measure of disorder the
kind of Matchbox uh state looks a bit
more disordered on the right than it is
on the left because there are more
possible ways to arrange the matches
like they are on the right hand side
than they are on the left hand side
right there's only one way to neatly
line them all up but there's loads of
different ways you could have for like
putting them any which way so there's
more posts to go back to the earlier
um discussion of the the molecules in
the gas
there's more possible ways that the
system can be in this disordered State
than there are in the state on the left
hand side so if imagine the the gas if
you have it confined to a small corner
of the room
there's a certain number of ways that
the the molecules could be arranged now
imagine that it can uh explore the whole
room
there's now loads more different
possible positions that each gas
molecule could have and so there's a lot
more possible microstates so this is the
sense in which uh there's more possible
microstates associated with the matches
on the right hand side than on the left
hand side and that's one way of thinking
that the entropy of the state of the
system on the right hand side is higher
than the entropy on the left hand side
and and this has been you know famously
connected to the direction of time the
idea that entropy can't uh decrease is
meant to somehow give us the arrow of
time and it's very controversial how you
do that but one thing that's important
to notice is there's two laws about time
asymmetry and thermodynamics so um
there's this lovely paper by uh two
philosophers of physics Josephine and
Harvey brown where they say well you
know there's not just the second law and
there's of course also the first law and
the zeroth law of thermodynamics there's
also another law the minus first law
which is kind of a presupposition of the
whole Theory which is that a system will
approach a state of equilibrium remember
that was uh the state where the macro
parameters weren't changing in time so
the the volume and pressure and
temperature don't change
um it will approach that state from the
non-equilibrium state so that's to say
if we put the ice cube in the glass of
water the system will eventually reach a
state of equilibrium where the
temperature is the same throughout the
whole glass of water the volume's
constant and the pressure's constant as
the Ice Cube melts eventually the system
will reach a state of equilibrium and
they say this is so Central to
thermodynamics they could even be called
the minus infamous law is that that
important okay so now hopefully you've
got a little bit of an idea about what
thermodynamics is so now on to the
demons
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas